i mean look we got this story right here
from nbc news biden administration to
fill uh border wall gaps near yuma
arizona
let me just uh break this story down for
you in a simple tweet from defiant else
karine jean-pierre tweeted in 2019
where are the pesos for your bigoted
wall to real donald trump today she says
that uh they're filling major gaps in
the border wall because biden is trying
to save lives oh
these people have no logic there's no
morals it is just whatever their tribe
wants meaningless but i'm curious your
thoughts on this like why would the butt
administration be doing anything in
filling gaps in the border wall
if they're failing us to this degree i'm
i have no idea is it like their quota is
done like okay that's all we needed
close the walls you know well i mean
it's
the truth is that the issue of illegal
immigration has been a football that's
been passed back between republicans and
democrats for years and nothing really
changes when it goes back and forth it's
always been a disaster it's always been
a massive problem honestly something
that's not really recognized is the
southern border program that obama
brought in place in 2014 was actually
massively successful he reduced illegal
migration from southern america by 70
percent by putting mass funding into
checkpoints walls patrols down on the
guatemalan border so there are actually
if you look back and forth between
republicans and democrats their policies
aren't that different the whole thing is
just a disaster that they're all
terrified to address in a strong
confident way because no one wants to be
seen as the president that stopped all
of the poor refugees or children from
coming in whatever the policy will be
publicly but they know they can't just
have
millions of people with no jobs no
background checks nothing sitting in
texas i figured it out remember that
story we were talking about the other
day where mexican citizens were getting
angry that americans were coming down
and they weren't speaking spanish
biden's building the wall to stop
americans from escaping
he's like no they're trying to get out
quick put something through got to bring
them in
got to bring them in oh man yeah
the interesting thing is why
even if they want immigration for like
supposed economic reasons why all from
central and south america
like there's tons of immigrants from
european countries that would love to
come here i mean there's tons of
ukrainians that would love to come here
so i have
my friends who are in europe
talk about how difficult it is to get a
visa to fly to the u.s and they they say
you know everyone knows you fly to
mexico you can walk in and you're fine
but when you try to do it legally they
make it like impossible my wife is still
going through immigration and it's been
since 2017. and she said she's from the
netherlands yeah i mean that's the eu
easy yeah right you walk around she
speaks perfect english and she's married
to us citizen right and we have three
kids wow the cartel offer like full
board deals for people that are
typically from asia
era arab countries a lot of places you
can pay like 50 grand to get traffic
through mexico into the us
as someone that has money that just
doesn't want to wait for the official
system i was meeting nigerians in
reynosa that were like actually i'm just
walking up to canada this is just easier
than applying for a visa i'm visiting a
friend in nova scotia is what one guy
told me
and he figured he'd take the route
through mexico and through the u.s
instead of just waiting on a visa
because it was easier
it's just crazy didn't you
were you were looking at americans who
were fleeing into canada
americans fleeing into canada yeah
didn't you go up and track that story
something like oh haitians that that was
a while back yeah there were haitians
walking through
roxanne road up into uh quebec i believe
um that felt they were going to get
deported by trump after their refugee
status had
gone up and they were going to get sent
back to haiti we opened our whole
stadium there for them and it was it was
wild because
you could literally just take a taxi to
this suburban neighborhood walk across
this pathway and the canadian police
were sitting there and they'd pick up
your luggage for you and just walk you
down to the stadium and give you a bed
there's no we have no borders it's all a
joke and i i don't blame any migrant for
coming in illegally when this is what
they watch on the news it's like okay i
guess this is how your system works your
cops are literally waiting there for us
with buses and we'll take our luggage
for us and this happens in texas too
they've got buses ready to transport
them they're like come on in whatever
what would they have done in 1960 if
this was happening
we had very different immigration in
1960 like it wasn't
you know we didn't have the mass welfare
state
states that we do now right if you came
in it was like you're working or you're
dying so we didn't have so many people
that didn't have jobs and didn't have
support systems migrating it was people
that were ready to come in and die or
work
right
but now they're getting unemployment or
like now that we've got massive support
systems the immigration is very
different okay what if
we built huge treadmills
or you know
no better yet
platforms
that when you when you step on them
it spins a gear which generates power so
when all of these people are illegally
crossing the border they're all
trampling these things pushing these
boxes down generating electricity
and
powering our grid sounds like slavery
with extra steps bud
i don't know what did we do
and then if they're planting like
pollinator flowers to to bring the bees
back no no like what we do is
as they cross the border they get
blasted with pollen so they're running
through this field pressing buttons with
pollens you know just pouring off their
bodies and then
once they get in
we take them and immediately put them in
a pneumatic tube which sends them back
to their country i can't wait for the
media matters article on this idea back
to the tube yes tim makes rick and morty
reference
they're outraged by it no my point is
rather sarcastic as to what the us
government is actually doing
the they're creating second class
citizens they're talking about giving
ideas to these people so they can have
benefits okay so they can't vote they'll
struggle to find work
but they'll let them be here to work
yeah they're creating serfs the the
democratic party and their republican
neocon cohorts
they're creating a surf class yeah i'm
not for that i'm not i'm not for that i
think people should enter legally they
should be treated respectfully i don't
think non-citizens should vote but if
you're a legal resident with the right
to work then congratulations we can hang
out we can correct beers and then pastor
citizens citizenship test understand
what this country means and why it means
what it means
come and vote man we're excited to have
you but just letting anybody come in at
any time
nah man and when your goal is to reduce
racism in society or whatever which is
what many progressives claim their goal
is do you really think that's going to
happen when the only if you're living in
a poor you know white neighborhood
growing up and then a bunch of people
come in and the only thing they do is
they can't speak the same language as
you they only work lowest class minimum
wage jobs that like you're creating this
perception in society of us and them
when you don't have any sort of
assimilation that takes place and
there's no differences in groups of
people that come in it's all just one
very low working class
you know non-integrated group of people
that's like a recipe for disaster
they're creating and i don't i hope they
realize i think they realize what
they're doing if they do realize damn
that's dark
yeah the assimilation part is
interesting because like if you i mean
why do people say new york is so lonely
when there's so many people it's it's i
mean like
i wouldn't go so far as to say that's
absolutely true but when you have people
in the same neighborhood that for one
maybe can't speak the same language but
they don't belong to the same culture
that right there creates separation in
the very same neighborhood
you know there's there's something about
like
that that kind of rips the story apart
that kind of holds together like why is
this going to be a good neighborhood at
all you got to be a part of the same
story and that doesn't seem like that's
a a care for any of any of the
immigrants it's it doesn't seem like you
know come in and as you were saying
understand what this you know nation is
uh or or what bonds us together
regardless of the nation like what bonds
us together and that's what my wife was
saying about holland it was just this
influx of immigration and there was this
rift not just language-wise but like a
lot of the immigrants as she was saying
and she saw it just did not care about
the culture or the glue that that
connected the people the swedish prime
minister has come out just um a few
months ago and said we are living in two
parallel societies and this is a
left-wing swedish prime minister not
right-wing anyways and and she's like
yeah it's becoming a crisis in our
country these people are not
assimilating they're not getting jobs
they're not speaking the same language
we've got two countries they're 30 years
too late yep so uh i went down to sweden
and i was hearing all this rhetoric from
people on the right saying that
the the refugees were creating all this
crime
i went there and found not true actually
completely not true i mean a little bit
but not really like the narrative of
migrant refugees burning cars and stuff
some of those things were happening the
reality was the children
swedish citizens
descendants of somali migrants from the
90s
were
are the cause of a lot are the ones
perpetrating a lot of the crime the
reason was
when the somali refugees and migrants
came to sweden in the 90s they said just
put them all in one place and forget
about them
so these people had no incentive to
learn the language and no ability to get
jobs because swedes are extremely racist
it is it is it is like everything you
think about wokes you know wokism sweden
they claim to be for diversity but
they're extremely racist so these are
the kind of people that will be like oh
yeah you know racism is so wrong and
it's like here's a migrant
don't bring that person near me so what
they did was they put all the somali
migrants in places like rinkaby is one
place i think it was
where a lot of somali people end up
living they have kids
those kids are raised by people of
somali descent
they're treated by swedish by other
people in sweden by native swedes as
immigrants even though they were born
there speak the language and are
citizens they go home to visit their
their families on their parents side in
somalia and they're called swedish
they're not called so they have no
country so what happens when the police
come into their neighborhoods they say
you are not a part of our society at all
you are just people in a van as far as
we're concerned you can't do anything
here so we actually had this was like
one of the most contentious moments when
we had cops tell us they start throwing
stones at us what can we do
we just leave that happened to us in
paris years and years ago do you
remember when we were in that no-go zone
in paris and the cops told us like if
something happens you're on your own
which one was this was that was are you
sure i was you were there i'm pretty
sure you were there oh wait wait wait
wait there were riots going on yeah
remember we left you in the falafel
store to die
and we couldn't get back to the to the
airbnb or whatever or something like
that yeah they started yelling at us
that they were going to kill us and our
translator said that and we were like
where's tim when we were going to find
our car and you were in the falafel
store like that's all i remember like
that was me absolutely sure i did a
video on it really shout out to falafel
and you were like forget tim we need to
go
for real
maybe i need to watch the video to
remember
years ago yeah i do remember in france
like there were big protests and the
trains were blocked off and the cops
wouldn't let anyone through and stuff
like that we went to a few yeah
yeah yeah yeah northern parts of france
i think i remember this there was like a
lot of crime there were shootings
and and locals were like scared
i remember when i went to sweden the
first time this guy was scared to drive
in certain neighborhoods
because he was just like these
neighborhoods have become like their own
you know they colloquially call them
no-go zones and then the media was like
there's no such thing as a no-go zone
and you look at the definition and it's
like a no-go zone is an area where you
know
there's like high crime or p police tell
you to avoid
and like you either can't go there
you're told to avoid going there and so
in these areas like you actually had
swedish police issue statements saying
like these are high crime areas but then
deny that they were in any way no go
zone and i'm like my attitude was
i don't care what they're officially the
locals just refer to them that way and
the cops too the cops will say it too
they're like this is a no-go zone just
so you know oh but those don't exist by
the way yeah just don't say that does it
compare to a favela
i think favelas are awesome because i i
mean at least when i was in brazil
favelas were just like
shanty towns you know in brazil
regular people live in regular lives
they're just you know poorer and so the
crazy thing was how people built houses
on top of and through other people's
houses
so like we went to one house
where they have a neighbor the neighbor
one day just climbed up on top of the
roofs and started building another house
to get to it they have to go through the
house nobody cares i was like wow that's
kind of crazy i haven't seen that but
i've been to some favelas that i would
never go back to what is a favela it
means that this is shantytown yeah like
in brazil it's it's is it supposed to be
like a dangerous area is that the yeah
and it's it's definitely the lowest
economic areas and sometimes they're
right next to like a high economic area
those are the most dangerous one there's
like a contrast if you go to super poor
areas in the world where there's no
contrast there's no like jealousy or
like trying to strive for that wealth or
whatever people are perfectly content
it's when there's that like developing
societies are really rough i don't know
man i mean maybe they're dangerous but
maybe because i'm from chicago it just
didn't feel that way to me like no i
mean that literally could be because you
know they say chicago's my chicago's got
more gun deaths than iraq going to bed
at night in the city and then hearing
gunshots in the distance it's just
something you grow up with have like
someone pulling out a gun at wait at my
local high school fight breaks out and
somebody pulls out a gun it's just like
i'm in i'm in the favelas in brazil and
it's like a dude with like an open fire
just grilling chicken and we're like is
cool they're like playing music and
people were just chilling and i was like
i don't know have you seen city of god
no
it's it's all about the favelas really
really good story but it's about how
like the the the children gangs gangs
that were literally like kids from maybe
four or five years old all the way up to
like 15 with guns were like running some
of these favelas you know what you got
to understand though is that uh most
people aren't insane
you know what i mean like i don't know
about that one but no i mean
there are insane people but i typically
find in in my my travels having covered
you know conflict crisis uh being in
these like being in uh anarchists
districts in like turkey
is that their goal there there's a goal
there's an idea there's like you can see
what they're doing and why they're doing
it they're not the joker so like
when i'm in the favelas they're like
here's likely what's going to happen
like if someone wants to steal from you
they're going to take your stuff
i was i was warned when i was in
venezuela they were like when you get
expressed kidnapped in venezuela they'll
give you a ride anywhere you want to go
like their goal is to take your money
not to destroy your life for the most
part so they one guy told me a story
where he was like he went to an atm
machine and as soon as he walked up guy
walked up to him and said you know take
your money out and then now get in the
car
they're driving in the car and they're
like
there's a guy pointing a gun and he's
like give me your wallet give me your
stuff give me your phone give me all
your cash where can we drop you off and
he's like oh you can drop me off here
and like it was like a 20 minute drive
and then like drove him there like man
have a go and he was like all right bye
that's nice of them well cause like
there are bad people some of these
people will kill you but if you look at
some of these videos out of brazil you
see them so so often where someone's
robbing a store and they get shot and
killed
you may notice
like in these videos the dude robin is
not
prepared to shoot anyone like have you
seen these videos i think i know the
idea you're talking about tons of them
yeah a guy will walk into a store and
then he'll pull out a gun and start
pointing and then everyone just unloads
on him the dude will try and run away
because they were threatening these
people but not really prepared to
actually do it but when you point a gun
at someone they're prepared to defend
their own lives this is the issue these
people they're doing these robberies
they're not actually prepared to hurt an
innocent person but these people with
the guns aren't innocent so those people
are my point is in my experience having
been to a lot of countries
if you just try and understand the
people and their motivations you're
typically fine that's a really good
point i think the people you have to be
the most scared of are it's the classic
thing the people who have nothing left
to lose like you never get in a fight
with a crackhead you're gonna lose every
time or at least they're to gouge your
eyes out then before or like
you look at like the situation where
those two girls were beheaded in morocco
in the mountains by these migrants who
had been sitting there for years trying
to get over the into sueto maria milia
over the fences and they just
they can't go back don't have enough
money destroyed their passports can't go
forward
nothing left to lose let's chop these
girls heads off after assaulting them
like geez those are the scary but you're
right people have motivations that you
can identify
you might be fine right but that also
means like when you're seeing someone
when you see isis you're like i know
their motivations run yeah yeah yeah
like the average person so my point is
like you're going to a fella the average
motivation for a person is i'm going to
get food for my family i'm gonna get
nice clothes and try and just live so
then when they come up to and they
threaten you it's like if you just give
them your stuff
they're gonna leave you alone or
you can figure out you know are they
really prepared to fight with you and if
typically you see this in the united
states too they did this uh study
they got a bunch of [ __ ]
convicted criminals who had committed
armed robberies
showed them videos of people walking and
asked them who would they choose to
target
turns out like over 80 of the time the
people they chose had been robbed before
there was something about the way people
carried themselves that made them look
weaker and susceptible so that's you can
understand these things for the most
part when i would go to like the favelas
you know that almost all people don't
want trouble like
a fox for instance
will not come onto our property when the
dog's around unless the fox is starving
and it has no choice and that's the
issue so most people like when you when
you come across someone who's like
desperate
they might you know not want to destroy
you but they'll take your stuff the real
scary thing is ideologues because you
know they want to destroy you because
those people are crazy
depending on where you are like there
was that one story about the two people
riding their bikes through tajikistan or
whatever and then isis just random
rammed them and like ran them over or
whatever because like you know
some places are
dominated by ideologues and zealots you
gotta watch out for that i tell you this
i would gladly with a smile on my face
walk through any favela in brazil
going to stores hanging out with people
and not worry about it
but i would be much much more worried to
go to like
a protest in new york city where there's
leftists you know what i mean yeah cause
i know they're i know their motivations
the motivations on the left is violence
bricks anger and rage they'll scream in
your face they'll they'll do what they
did to andy know and if a vela it's
people they want to sell you a
cheeseburger man yeah cheeseburger might
you know have worms in it depending on
who you're getting cooked from but
no no one there wants to be
known on the internet as the guy who
threw a brick at tim's pool's head like
it doesn't they don't care that they're
sure yeah yeah no there's whereas new
york that's probably if you don't really
you know what's really messed up though
is the favela tours they started doing a
while ago where rich tourists will get
on buses and drive through poor
neighborhoods as a tourist attraction
that's disgusting that is super nasty
geez i feel like i'm looking at images
of favelas thinking about how cool they
look they do i'm kind of like that that
guy on taking a tour right now but you
pull up the image he's just doing it on
the internet it's a spectacular
spectacular imagery to see the way they
build these houses in these communities
well i mean they're like doctors filled
with any
yeah there's probably no structural
integrity like there's no building codes
and whatever getting getting from
building the building is the craziest
thing because there's like zigzagging
narrow quarters like one human body
length wide
i went to uh uh uh uh what was it um
what is it called it it's uh
policia i think my portuguese it doesn't
it's not existent they had they had
built a mock favela for trainings
for for favela policing and po and
combat because the favelas are random
you know like in in in the states it's a
grid system we use for most cities so
there's a logic there's a logic to it
but in favelas it's like you're going to
turn the corner and some guy's going to
pop out of a window that was really fun
when i went down there because we
climbed on top of their mock favela and
i think it was like 8 feet or 10 feet
and then i asked the cop and i was like
what do you do when you're up here and
the guy down guys down there and he's
like and then he jumps down he's like
just like that and then i jumped down
after him and he was like whoa he was
like don't get hurt man i'm like i'm
good and he was actually really
surprised i did it because you know he
thought like we do training here we can
handle it and i'm like i've been skating
yeah you skateboard i was like i can
jump off a building i'm good i bet
they're pretty good at parkour oh yeah
no for real man
that's that's why the police needed to
build this place
build a mock favela for training because
you try to chase down a dude who lives
there home field advantage yeah
no but seriously it's a maze
i'm telling you i went to one house to
get to the neighbor's house you had to
walk through their kitchen like walk
through their house to get to the next
house this is like perfect assassin's
creed territory yeah there's jump
everywhere all over the but they well
the crazy thing is the power lines
because yeah but they've been they've
been doing for a while now something
called reclamation or pacification where
they've been sending in these like
high-powered
tactical units rifles to just clear out
the gangs
the gangs
were the real government of the favelas
yeah because there was no government so
what happens is the gangs they'd call
them started to like locals would
organize and come up with their own
systems of governance that's what humans
do
when the government tried to say like
hey these people should be paying taxes
and we should have control of this
they went in and started rounding these
people up shooting them in many
circumstances it was pretty brutal just
another gang
yup you know there's a pretty euphoric
way to get mugged in uh i think it's
like ecuador and colombia they use toei
or scopolamine where you just like
it's this powder that you can put on a
piece of paper and they'll go up to like
tourists and they just blow it in their
face and then makes you so suggestible
that you're like
all right can you can you go to the atm
can you pull out all the cash that you
have and not take me back to your hotel
or wherever you're staying where where
are your valuables and you'll just say
it you'll give it up and people are are
shocked they like don't remember yeah
they blow it in your face it's the
zombie drug yeah it's i think it's the
strongest nightshade scopolamine
scopolamina
don't think it comes that's a really
respectable respectable way to mug
someone right that's very i'd like to
get mugged that way someday yes yeah
chemically if i'm going to get mugged
that's going to be the one no i'll do it
regardless
they call it the devil's breath the
scopolamine yeah some put it in
ayahuasca as well they call it toei but
they make it an administer admixture of
uh ayahuasca and then sometimes people
get taken advantage of that way but i
kind of feel like
it's gotta be uh
an urban legend the potency of
scopolamine
you know maybe
like these stories of people
someone will like walk up to them at the
atm and then do like the witch doctor
thing where they go and bloat in your
face and then you're like
and then they zombify you that's crazy
like how does that actually happen you
know
i wonder the same thing about treats
motion sickness oh okay
yeah
is there what were you gonna say well i
was just like the i was just reading
this thing in this weird magazine crime
thought nachos crime about me
about pcp and like leading it you know
to cannibalism pcp leading people into
cannibalism and how many stories
came up with that oh when i was in
mexico something really interesting i
was told was that you know all the human
sacrifices they did in like what was it
mayan culture
sorry the aztecs not like um they were
telling me that they'd put the people on
like shrooms and tons of different drugs
and they actually wanted to be
sacrificed because they thought it was
like such a noble important death and
when they were on all these drugs it was
actually like this beautiful experience
it made um people's hearts being eaten a
lot more lovely for me
romantic what if that's how you ascend
you take dmt until you blast off sending
your spirit into the fourth dimension
then they sacrifice your body
severing the tether and keeping you
trapped in the fourth dimension you're
on another level right now man i feel
like i'm on dmt so your spirit's already
in the other dimension you don't have to
experience the visceral transaction
you're already peacefully there and then
they kick you down and fly the steps and
your friends eat your heart that's cute
yeah if you guys watch it what was that
apocalypto yeah yeah yeah yeah i think
did you guys watch vikings i haven't
seen it no wasn't that like a thing in
vikings too uh where they'd talk about
how it it was like a huge honor to be
sacrificed to the gods and people would
want to get that position
it was definitely i mean i don't i don't
know how much vikings is like
referencing historical information but i
just know that's like a theme
the litho ancient lithuanian um cults
and stuff would do that for sure
what are these pagan
they would even take body parts or eat
body parts of you know the conquered
peoples
well i guess that's
yeah this is still a thing today you
have like isis members they're like bam
i'm gonna blow myself
reading reading the crime about
scopolamine they don't blow it in your
face they just lace your drink with it
so is there a video of someone getting
dosed with scopolamine and then being
like yes master or anything like that no
it just it's a roofie like i'm reading
about it it just makes you like
delirious and loopy so you're probably
like wow
and then they're like what's your atm
number and you go
i kind of feel like there's going to be
a youtuber that's like today i'm going
to get hannibal
one of the very early things was like
they got some scopolamine and they were
like whoa and they flush down the toilet
they don't touch it i saw this one yeah
there was a vice anchor that would go
out and do a bunch of drugs is it
hannibal is that his name animal no it's
uh hamilton hamilton
what's up
hannibal hannibal's pharmacopoeia yeah
um hamilton's pharmaceuticals
hamilton's like for i'm gonna do this
for you and then he would take all these
different trunks and be like now you
know what it's like for me to be on
drugs
that's a lot of great work he did wasn't
his dad a famous guy who's his dad
i can't remember but you're right yeah
i met him and he really does talk that
slow
oh cool thanks for checking out this
segment from the tim cast irl podcast
but if you want to check out the full
show live tune in monday through friday
at 8pm and if you want more special
access content head over to timcast.com
and become a member your membership
helps sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there